never been in
a proper prison if anything kicks off
and it goes a little bit pear-shaped and
it's not love you a friendly place to be
in the middle of Britain's prison
population is exploding it's increased
by twenty two thousand in the last
decade I cost almost two billion a year
just seems a complete waste the amount
of money that we spend to keep these
guys in there this is costing us a
fortune there are some prison work
schemes the government's say they want
to create more but in cash-strapped
Britain few offenders graph full-time to
pay anything back the whole purpose of
this is to get in there set up a
business and to get them crafting so I'm
giving my time and energy to see if I
can get offenders earning nice Gordon
Ramsay it's taken nine months to
persuade the Ministry of Justice to let
me try and set up my pilot business in
the notorious HMP Brixton
sorry that will
my husband the governor's put the word
out about my idea and a few of the
prisoners are curious about my plan to
cook on the inside and sell on the
outside that's the way I do my boss loan
yeah
Brixton is a Victorian category be
prison with 800 inmates
locked up for anything from shoplifting
to murder
mr. Ramsey Chloe are you doing how I
Mart where stuff welcome to Brixton
thank you
okay uh you've handed all your personal
items into the gate there
oh yeah phone and phone and everything
like that I remind you to do that every
day that you can sell it okay let's go
inside
officer mark Westgard is taking me into
the heart of the prison here the prisons
are kept in their cells up to 21 hours a
day if he tries to mug me off uh putting
on his place I'm Aneta no problem sorry
it to be made fun of by him or anyone
else a lot of these people play movies
and their life change would I figure
Andy he can be a bit fierce with people
that he's working with yeah that's what
we do I think he would leave a few
people along the way that's how it goes
you know only the strong survive
the prisoners are housed in five
separate wings I have no idea who I'm
going to be working with if it can they
change the world I don't think he will
and I don't think long term it's gonna
it'll be a winner I'm how many prisoners
are in Oh
90% of the criminals on this wing have
serious drug or alcohol problems
you know just on TV I need a better with
you to fit [ __ ] have you got one in the
middle coming you know that's just one
gap just that that's what silly boy
can you cook because of the book what
was the last thing he killed last fall
that girl philosophy Nicole laughing I
cook with paella oh yeah why I love to
cook while are mean Arriba Sam yeah miss
Abram how I said over 20 years ago I got
dealt a dysfunctional cars
my little brother became a heroin addict
and my father became an alcoholic
designs range from disastrous yoga
nozzles going to go inside the bag
you didn't to her to the delectable